Matt LeBlanc with the cool helmet can I
just show you one theme here I'm gonna
show you one cool thing day all right
okay we're gonna watch a terrible
quality version of this he's like the
badass Iron Man before there was iron
man that's pretty special it's pretty
specialist it probably the only thing I
remember hey reject nation Greg Alva
here look who it is what's your name
Brianne Chandler also known as Miss
movies miss movies she has a YouTube
channel you guys have seen her on her
before she also makes cameos on the
Schmo down she was on movie fights a
couple weeks ago I'm everywhere she's
everywhere know where she is
that's not true you are dominating the
movies fear of the youtubes Brienne lost
in space
yes Netflix TV series my hair is gonna
be one of Netflix's another expensive
endeavor they're doing these danger Will
Robinson danger I grew up on the lost in
space movie which should have been
franchised I think it had Joey come on I
remember working at Blockbuster and this
bean in the new release section but I
never ever saw it oh god the theme song
and then the quarter drops the part of
it let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
look how expensive this is I want to
know how many subs
[Music]
this is Will Robinson
the 24th colonists
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like flying to the Navigator thing
yeah so neat he said the Lord
[Music]
seems like a movie
[Music]
[Music]
not just the white family
[Music]
if you have any hope of saving your
Stanley
that looks like the most expensive
[Laughter]
though eggs are really cool I'm I'm
actually genuinely shocked by how great
and by how grand
everything looks I have said this before
the Netflix movies the trailers for the
Netflix movies feel like trailers for
shows and then the trailers for their
shows feel like movies yeah cuz this
felt like a trailer for one giant movie
and it's kind of shocking to know this
is gonna be a TV series because of how
massive and scale it is and how great
the effects actually look parker parker
posey is pointing parker posey i said it
was ally sheedy she's playing dr. Smith
dr. Smith is a dude but I guess now it's
a girl yeah yeah I'm all about that
Brianne well about that don't you worry
about it man I'm all about that you know
who played dr. Smith in the lost in
space movie no I don't know who Gary
Oldman he's a man and now we have the
gender swap which I'm all about good
Toby Stephens yeah Toby Stephens great
actor beyond it's like scope and stuff
it seems like it's really honing in on
its themes though of survival and
exploration in space I know they had
like a new Star Trek show right now we
got the Star Trek movies the Star Wars
movies this does feel like it has
something different to offer though in
terms of its tone because the idea of
the family exactly that's what makes
lost in space rather unique it's not a
bunch of strangers or just a crew
working together this is a family who
are
lost in space and still doing their
space exploration but it seems to have
this real epic survival theme about it
of them really trying to just make it
out of this alive right now while
encountering a bunch of danger along the
way know if Netflix is planning on doing
a Land of the Lost yeah I don't know man
I think that movie wolf Rose very
underrated yeah want to see does not
equate to quality Netflix very true and
I don't have time to watch all that
stuff nor do I want to so then it's
gonna be a matter of like oh what looks
the best or what do i graphics look
great
the performances look solid and they've
cut out all the camp eNOS of the sixties
vibe the robot the one that is close
with Will Robinson it looks like it
could be kind of scary too actually and
it looks like they have 10 episodes so
the first season will have 10 episodes
good good good a hundred million dollars
in episode what do you think of the new
lost in space trailer does it look
better than the 90s movie nothing will
be better than that nothing all right
guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell get
notified every time one of our bids is
up check us out on patreon full-length
TV show a music video reactions over
there as well as weekly Q&A s last but
not least the most important thing you
must do for my life is follow Brienne
Chandler on the Miss movies YouTube
channel follow her on social media every
link for her life is in the description
box her personal home address is there
her personal email
yeah Amazon wishlist her login
information Amazon all their user Prime
she won't notice see you guys